And what's the latest
on Asian bae, by the way?
Y'all still good?
Asian bae!
With the samurai dick.
Uh, samurai are Japanese,
racist.
Hmm, prove it.
(SCOFFS) Whatever,
I already heard this story.
Y'all talk.
(GROANS) Oh, okay,
I didn't think this through,
and...
you know the hair's fucking
with my balance.
Wait, wait, what's happening?
What story?
Y'all fucked already?
What that dick do?
-Or do it don't do?
-Oh, no, it do.
It definitely do.
But it's been almost a month
and I'm just not feeling close
to him.
It's weird.
It's all good sex
and witty banter, but...
Hold up, hold up, hold up.
He dicks you down,
makes you laugh,
and he don't work
at the airport?
What's the problem?
'Cause I don't hear it.
He's just not opening up.
And meanwhile,
I'm telling him everything.
I even told him
how I had to wear a helmet
to bed till I was 11.
Are you sure you're not looking
for something?
Don't pick up nothing
that don't serve you, girl.
I-- I'm not,
I promise you I'm not.
So it's just you talking
the whole time?
Basically.
And then we fuck...
And, I'm not mad at that part,
but,
I just don't wait it to turn
into fucking is all we do.
You know, I've been there before
and I want more.
Yeah.
KELLI: I-- I'm with Issa.
Who wants to sit around
and listen to a grown man
talking about his feelings?
You know what I want?
I want me a mime
with a big dick.
I'll be happy as hell.
I gotta find a circus.
But if she has real feelings,
then she needs
to let those skeletons
out the closet now.
Tiff might be right.
Andrew and I need to have
-some real ass conversations.
-Mm-hmm.
I think I might have
to slow it down.
(WINCES) You gon' put that pussy
on pause?
(LAUGHS)
Yes, I am.
-Okay girl, mute that monkey.
-(DOORBELL RINGING)